well new tonight at six o'clock Afghani
families in Las Vegas chasing the hope
of a better life nearly 18 months now
after the Taliban took over their home
country 8 news now reporter Joshua
peguero shares the story of one Refugee
family still working to settle into
their new life
support Pastor remembers the Bomb Blast
that nearly sunk her family's chance of
Escape
we were grateful and thankful that
luckily we came to America well Paul
speaks a language called Dory and we
spoke to her through an interpreter in
August of 2021 two suicide bombers
killed nearly 200 people near the Cabo
International Airport in Afghanistan
including 13 U.S troops popal was in
that area but managed to get past the
security checkpoint
from that moment on the soldiers
American soldiers treated us very
respectfully they treated us very well
well Paul and her five daughters left
Afghanistan right before the Taliban
took back power they immediately banned
the girls from going to school beyond
the sixth grade
the whole world is a witness of the
current situation as as everyone knows
that in Afghanistan there are the girls
are not allowed permitted to go to
school the journey to Las Vegas with
Afghanistan wasn't straight for the
family they first went to Qatar after
Afghanistan they're to Germany and after
that they spent three months outside of
military camp in Virginia where they've
learned about the resources to get their
kids enrolled in a public school one of
football's daughters attends Bonanza
High School her teacher Ryan Slaughter
says he helped the family drawing
inspiration from his own family's
immigration from Italy five daughters in
a weekly that's terrible
my heart breaks for things like that and
I want to provide but I'm a teacher so
when you're a teacher it's like man
there's nothing nothing comes out
Catholic Charities helps refugees
resettle in the state and they help
families like for Paul as you might
imagine it's a big leap from wherever
they're coming from to hear as it would
be for us going the other way so we try
to orient them to you know how to handle
the banking
industry or how to do things as simple
as go grocery shopping as for Paul she's
grateful for the freedoms her five
daughters now have they got Michael I
want my daughters to reach out to become
Medical Professional Engineers be a
professor in a college and study
journalism dreams and careers that are
possible in the US Joshua figuero eight
news now